WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET ALONG I
THINK IF WE SOLVE ALL THE
WORLD’S PROBLEMS.
>> Tucker: AMEN.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY
TONIGHT.
IF YOU ARE OVER THE MASS
HYSTERIA, IF YOU ARE
OVERPOLITICIZING, WEAPONIZING OF
THE CORONAVIRUS YOU ARE NOT
ALONE.
THAT’S WHY TONIGHT WE ARE
FOCUSED ON TWO MAJOR STORIES.
FIRST, WE ARE GOING TO CALL OUT
ANYONE AND EVERYONE WHO IS USING
THIS VIRUS AS A POLITICAL WEAPON
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
IT’S SICK, IT’S SAD BUT
PREDICTABLE.
I’M SURE IN THE END THE MOB AND
THE MEDIA THEY WILL BE ADVANCING
THEIR NEW CONSPIRACY THEORY AND
NEWEST HOAX, PROBABLY THEY WILL
COME UP WITH HYPOTHETICALLY I’M
JUST GUESSING WOULDN’T SHOCK ME
PRESIDENT TRUMP, PUTIN MAD
SCIENTISTS RUSSIA AND UKRAINE
MANUFACTURING THE CORONAVIRUS ON
PURPOSE SO THEY CAN HURT
INNOCENT CHILDREN AND KILL
GRANDMA AND GRANDPA BEFORE THEY
THROW THEM OVER A CLIFF BEFORE
THEY FEED THEM DOG FOOD.
LOOK, IT IS TIME, ALL
SERIOUSNESS, FOR SIMPLE
FUNDAMENTAL TRUTHS TO PROTECT
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS.
THAT MEANS DEMOCRATS.
THAT MEANS REPUBLICANS,
LIBERALS, CONSERVATIVES AND
LIBERTARIANS AND EVERYBODY IN
BETWEEN.
VIRUSES DO NOT HAVE A POLITICAL
IDENTITY.
SO, TONIGHT WE WILL SEPARATE
COLD HARD TRUTH FROM WHAT IS THE
MOB’S LATEST MANUFACTURED
IRRESPONSIBLE OVER THE TOP
RHETORIC.
OUR MEDICAL A TEAM AND DR. OZ
TONIGHT WILL EXPLAIN.
PLUS, COMING UP, WE WILL SHOW
YOU HOW DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA
NOW WANT YOU TO IGNORE REAL
CONCERNS ABOUT QUID PRO QUO JOE
AND HIS APPARENT AND HIS
INCREASING INABILITY TO COMPLETE
THOUGHTS AND DELIVER COGENT
SPEECH.
IT IS NOW SERIOUS CAMPAIGN
ISSUE.
BY THE WAY SERIOUS DEMOCRATS
WHEN RONALD REAGAN WAS RUNNING
FOR RE-ELECTION.
WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
WE START WITH THE MEDIA MOB’S
ONGOING EFFORT TO NOW USE A
VIRUS, AN INFECTIOUS DISEASE AS
A POLITICAL WEAPON ALL-TO-TO
BLUDGEON PRESIDENT TRUMP YET
AGAIN.
I HAVE SAID MANY TIMES IF HE
CURED CANCER THEY WOULD LIKELY
WANT TO IMPEACH HIM FOR CURING
CANCER.
NOW THE CORONAVIRUS IS A SERIOUS
DISEASE.
NOW, SHOULD YOU AND YOUR FAMILY
BE CONCERNED?
OF COURSE.
YOU SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FLU.
YOU SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT A
COLD.
YOU SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT
ANY HEALTH RISK.
SHOULD YOU BE INFORMED?
ABSOLUTELY.
DO WE ALL NEED TO TAKE NECESSARY
PRECAUTIONARY STEPS?
YES.
ALL OF US.
BUT THE COVERAGE WE ARE SEEING
FROM THE MEDIA AND THE MOB IS
BEYOND DESPICABLE AND POLITICAL.
FOR EXAMPLE, SUNDAY, YOU GOT
CHUCKY TODD BOASTING THE
CORONAVIRUS COULD ACTUALLY HELP
PRESIDENT TRUMP LIKE THE IRAN
HOSTAGE SITUATION HURT JIMMY
CARTER.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" EDITORIAL
CALLING IT PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
CHERNOBYL AND OVER THERE AT
STATE RUN CONSPIRACY TVMSDNC
POOR LIBERAL MORNING JOE SAYING
TRUMP’S STUPIDITY WILL CAUSE
AMERICANS TO DIE.
AND MEANWHILE JOYLESS REID
TELLING HER VIEWERS THAT THE
CHILDREN OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS
WERE LIKELY TO SPREAD THE
CORONAVIRUS TO OTHER KIDS.
JUST MADE THAT UP, I GUESS.
THAT’S WHAT THEY DO.
THE LIES, THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, THE PSYCHOTIC
ANTI-TRUMP RAGE, WELL, IT’S BEEN
NONSTOP.
SADLY, THIS IS ALL WE HAVE
GOTTEN FOR THREE-PLUS YEARS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT IS GOVERNMENT REALLY
FOR?
GOVERNMENT IS THERE TO PROTECT
FROM YOU TERRORISM, JUST EXACTLY
THIS THING.
THIS IS EXACTLY THE FUNCTION OF
GOVERNMENT AND OUR GOVERNMENT IS
SCREWING UP.
>> THIS MAY BE DONALD TRUMP’S
KATRINA.
THIS IS AN EVENT THAT COULD TAKE
DOWN A PRESIDENT.
>> THE IRAN HOSTAGE CRISIS WAS
THE FINAL YEAR OF CARTER’S
PRESIDENCY.
NOT HIS FAULT BUT IT’S A TEST IN
REALTIME.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS DOING
NOTHING BUT PLAYING IN HIS
POLITICAL SANDBOX WHILE THIS
VIRUS CONTINUES TO SPREAD
SILENTLY ACROSS AMERICA.
>> Sean: THESE PEOPLE SOUND LIKE
THEY REALLY CARE ABOUT THE
COUNTRY.
PROTECTING HUMAN LIFE OR JUST
LOOKING FOR EVERY AND ANY WAY
POSSIBLE TO BASH PRESIDENT
TRUMP?
LAST WEEK’S "NEW YORK TIMES"
EDITORIAL SPELLED IT OUT PRETTY
CLEARLY THEY NAMED THE
CORONAVIRUS THE TRUMP VIRUS AND
THEY WROTE IF YOU ARE FEELING
AWFUL, YOU KNOW WHO TO BLAME.
GETTING CLOSE TO THAT LAB
CONSPIRACY THEORY I WAS KIND OF
JOKING ABOUT.
THAT’S HOW SICK IT IS.
NOW THIS KIND OF COVERAGE HAS
SERIOUS RAMIFICATIONS WHY PEOPLE
PANIC.
CHAOS ENSUES.
RECENTLY A GROUP OF SHOPPERS
CAUGHT ON TAPE.
WHAT WERE THEY DOING?
THEY WILL BRAWLING.
WHAT WERE THEY BRAWLING OVER?
THE LAST PACK OF TOILET PAPER.
WE HAVE ALSO WITNESSED A RECENT
MARKET FELL OFF TODAY’S DROP HAD
MORE LIKELY TO DO WITH AN OIL
SUPPLY BATTLE BETWEEN THE
RUSSIANS AND SAUDIS THAN
ANYTHING KRON-RELATED BUT
MARKETS ARE SKIDDISH.
LET’S CUT THROUGH ALL THE
HYSTERIA AND ALL THE B.S.
LET’S GIVE YOU SOME SIMPLE TRUTH
AND FACTS.
HERE IS THE SURGEON GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
YOU DON’T BELIEVE DR. HANNITY?
LET’S LISTEN TO HIM.
I’M NOT A DOCTOR.
>> PEOPLE OVER THE AGE OF 60,
THEY ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
DEVELOP COMPLICATIONS FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS AND TO BE
HOSPITALIZED FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THE AVERAGE AGE OF DEATH IS AGE
80.
NOW, WHAT WE ALSO WANT
COMMUNITIES TO KNOW IS THAT IF
YOU ARE A CHILD OR YOUNG ADULT,
YOU ARE MUCH MORE -- YOU ARE
MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM THE FLU
IF YOU GET IT THAN YOU ARE TO
DIE FROM CORONAVIRUS.
SO THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT
BEING YOUNG THAT IS PROTECTIVE.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE REASSURED
BY THAT.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT WE
ARE REALLY FOCUSING IN ON THOSE
GROUPS THAT ARE AT HIGHEST RISK
FOR COMPLICATIONS.
>> Sean: JUST TO RECAP,
ACCORDING TO THE SURGEON GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES, PEOPLE
OVER 60, THEY ARE MOST AT RISK
FOR CORONA-RELATED COMPLICATIONS
OR HOSPITALIZATION.
NOW, THE AVERAGE AGE OF
MORTALITY IS 80.
YOUNG PEOPLE, UNLIKE H1N1 THAT
TENDED TO IMPACT YOUNGER KIDS
MORE THAN OLDER PEOPLE.
NOW, IN THIS CASE, OLDER PEOPLE
ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM
THIS -- OR FROM REGULAR FLU
ACTUALLY THAN FROM CORONAVIRUS,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
REMEMBER, DESPITE EARLY REPORTS
THE LIKELY MORTALITY RATE COULD
BE AS LOW AS 1%.
DR. FAUCI WAS OUT THERE IN THE
NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL IN THE FIRST
FEW HUNDRED CASES IN CHINA HE
WROTE, QUOTE:  THERE WERE NO
CASES IN CHILDREN YOUNGER THAN
THE AGE OF 15.
EITHER CHILDREN ARE LESS LIKELY
TO BECOME INFECTED OR THEIR
SYMPTOMS WERE SO MILD THAT THEIR
INFECTION ESCAPED DETEXAS.
AS A OLDER PERSON I WOULD RATHER
IT BE ON ME.
LET’S BE HONEST.
KIDS HAVE THEIR WHOLE LIVES IN
FRONT OF THEM.
IT’S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THIS
ADMINISTRATION TOOK
UNPRECEDENTED STEPS ON THE
CORONAVIRUS.
SERIOUSLY AND A LOT OF CRITICISM
TO BOOT.
NO PRESIDENT EVER, EXCEPT DONALD
TRUMP, EVER ACTED FASTER, EVER
ACTED SOONER, OR HAVE DONE MORE
TO STOP THE SPREAD OF AN
INFECTIOUS DISEASE.
KEEP IN MIND THE VIRUS WAS NOT
OFFICIALLY DETECTED AND NAMED
UNTIL JANUARY 7TH.
HO RECOGNIZED IT ON
DECEMBER 30TH OF LAST YEAR.
THAT’S PRETTY QUICK.
AND THEN ON JANUARY 31st, THE
PRESIDENT DECLARED A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND HE IS THE
ONE THAT ORDERED THE TRAVEL BAN
AND QUARANTINE WHICH WE HADN’T
DONE IN DECADES AND BY THE WAY
HE DID IT AGAINST THE ADVICE OF
MANY, BY THE WAY, THAT WERE
OFFERING HIM ADVISE OUT OF AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION.
THAT’S THE TRAVEL BAN TO CHINA.
THAT’S WHEN THAT BEGAN.
THREE WEEKS LATER, QUID PRO QUO
JOE BIDEN AND OTHERS CALLED THE
PRESIDENT FOR DOING IN THIS BAN
WAS XENOPHOBIA, FAKE NEWS CNN
SUGGESTING THE PRESIDENT IS
STIGMATIZING PEOPLE FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES.
AND FOR THE BETTER PART OF
FEBRUARY, NOW, WHAT WERE THE
DEMOCRATS DOING?
OH, THAT’S RIGHT.
THEY HARDLY ADDRESSED THE VIRUS
AT ALL.
THEY WERE TOO BUSY AND TOO
FOCUSED ON IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT OVER NOTHING.
NOW, THEY SEEM MORE INTERESTED
IN SCORING WHAT IS NOTHING BUT
CHEAP POLITICAL POINTS THAN
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROTECT OUR
AMERICAN FAMILY.
WE OUGHT TO PROTECT EVERY
AMERICAN LIFE HERE.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT ASKED FOR
LAWMAKERS TO HELP WITH THE
PAYROLL TAX CUT TO EASE
CORONA-RELATED ECONOMIC
CONCERNS.
THAT’S GOING TO HELP AND BE
IMPACTFUL TO SMALL BUSINESS,
HOURLY WAGE EARNERS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
HOPEFULLY DEMOCRATS WILL COME TO
THE TABLE AND DO WHAT’S RIGHT
FOR AMERICA AMERICA.
WILL THEY ALLEVIATE THE ECONOMIC
FALLOUT OF CORONA OR DO NOTHING
TO CONTINUE TO USE IT AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON, POLITICIZING A
DISEASE?
AGAIN, CORONAVIRUS IS A SERIOUS
MATTER.
IT’S NOT THE END OF DAYS.
SADLY, PANDEMICS, LIKE THIS,
HAPPEN MORE OFTEN THAN ANY OF US
WOULD LIKE.
H1N1 WORLDWIDE KILLED OVER ABOUT
HALF A MILLION PEOPLE ACCORDING
TO ESTIMATES.
THE U.S. HAS THE BEST DOCTORS.
BY THE WAY, H1N1 WE LOST NEARLY
14,000 AMERICANS.
WE HAVE THE BEST DOCTORS.
THE BEST RESEARCHERS, THE BEST
SCIENTISTS ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD
AND THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WILL CONTINUE TO AGGRESSIVELY
STOP THE SPREAD OF THIS
INFECTIOUS DISEASE.
WE ALSO FORGET PEOPLE THAT GET
FLU EVERY YEAR.
SOME YEARS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE DIE FROM THE FLU EVERY
YEAR PEOPLE DIE FROM THE FLU.
NOW, SHOULD WOULD HE BE SMART?
WISE?
LEARN THINGS HOW TO BE NEAT,
CLEAN -- YEAH.
OF COURSE.